these 17 one piece characters possess
the qualities of a king and are also
known as Supreme rulers their willpower
and ambition are so strong that they can
do anything they set their mind on and
today we'll cover all of them starting
with dark King Silver's Rayleigh
Rayleigh was one of Roger's most trusted
allies and one of the most powerful
combatants in the world during his prime
even years after his Heyday Rayleigh is
capable of using his conquerors hockey
at a frightening level we first
witnessed this during the salvage yard
when he easily rendered the owner of the
auctioning house unconscious and later
the entire hall room full of hostiles
what's more as seen in both of these
scenarios Egan seemingly choose specific
targets he wants to attack with his
hockey instead of attacking everyone in
his vicinity his knowledge and
understanding of this power are probably
one of the greatest in the series
shown-winning trained Luffy a complete
novice and turned him into a really
strong hockey user in only two years Oda
the author of One Piece stated that
Raley's conqueror hockey was at least
twice as potent as Luffy's by the time
of the Fishman island arc and that
Rayleigh could have knocked out all 100
000 of the new Fishman Pirates at the
end of each character I'll also rank how
strong their conqueror's hockey is and
based on all of this Rayleigh definitely
belongs in a tier Boa Hancock the pirate
Empress Bowe is the captain of the Kuja
Pirates and was the only female warlord
of the sea before the organization's
disbandment according to sandersonia and
herself boa possesses the ability to use
conquerors hockey while she has not yet
showcased her usage of it in the manga
we can actually see her using it in one
piece games burning blood and pirate
warriors 4. however since the events of
those games aren't Canon I'll
unfortunately have to put her in deter
for now Don Quixote doflamingo the
Heavenly demon doflamingo was one of the
strongest Warlords in the series as well
as the former World Noble and king of
drastrosa he first awakened his conquer
his hockey when he was around 10 years
old when being pursued by North Blue
citizens who tried to continuously
torture his family in Revenge knocking
them all out since then his proficiency
with it had increased greatly Asha when
he knocked out most of the G5 Marines at
Punk Hazard he also used it briefly in
his encounter with Luffy when their
strikes collided fighting on par with
the straw hat although we don't have
much information to go by when ranking
doflamingo's hockey it's evident that
he's very skilled in using it and
therefore I'll Place him in B tier Straw
Hat Luffy just like his tutor silver
Israeli Luffy managed to master all
three forms of hockey in a short period
of time Rayleigh even stated he has a
noticeable talent for hockey having
mastered the basic applications of all
three forms in only a year and a half
during pre-time skip we've seen Luffy
using conquerors hockey unintentionally
multiple times for example knocking out
multiple Kuja Warriors defeating the
attacking wolves and impal down knocking
out several Elite Marines at Marine Ford
and even using it repeatedly to destroy
the Subscribe button alright that last
one's maybe not entirely true but you
should definitely subscribe thanks
anyway over the two year time skip
Rayleigh taught him more about conqueror
hockey thus he finally gained conscious
control over it same as Rayleigh he
became capable of using it on only
designated targets without affecting
anyone else we first got to see the
extent of his new power on Fishman
Island where he instantly knocked out 50
50 000 members of the new Fishman
Pirates later in the story during the
raid on onigashima while fighting kaido
Luffy realized that he can Infuse
himself with hockey doing so on his arms
and legs which dramatically increases
his attack power combined with his
Advanced Armament hockey this allowed
him to deal immensely powerful blows
against kaido whereas his previous
attacks were too shallow however since
he only discovered this application of
conqueria's hockey a few moments prior
his control over it was crude and clumsy
leading to him being swiftly knocked
down by the emperor not long after when
Luffy and kaido Clash for the third time
barium dude conquers hockey attacks
cause clouds to part something that had
previously only ever occurred Whenever
two of the Emperors clashed against each
other or when Roger himself had fought
against one as such this might indicate
that Luffy's hockey has ascended to the
same level as that of the strongest
pirates in the world Don chinjal Qing
Zhao is a former pirate the leader of
the xinjiang family and the retired 12th
leader of the HAPO Navy in his golden
age when he was still a pirate he was
considered a rival to both GARP and
Roger and had a bounty of 542 million
bellies during one of his battles
against Garb the vice admiral punched
him so hard that his head flattened this
incident severely limited his power from
then on and shortly after he quit being
a pirate xinjiang shown the ability to
use conqueror's hockey during the
dressrosa arc when he knocked out many
of the competitors in Block C without
laying a finger on them this is an
impressive feat considering that most of
the participants in Korea Coliseum are
strong Fighters since xinjiang was one
of the most famous pirates of Azera his
conqueror's hockey should be at least in
a b tier Whitebeard the strongest man in
the world Edward nugate was one of the
most powerful pirates in history and
while he was still alive he held the
second biggest Bounty ever 5 billion 46
million bellies unfortunately due to his
illness we've never seen him using
conquerors hockey in the present
timeline however judging by flashbacks
from his Heyday he was an absolute beast
in using it he regularly clashed with
some of the one-piece Legends like Roger
and Odin and seemingly never lost a duel
the best example of his hockey Mastery
was displayed in chapter 966 when he
fought his longtime rival Goldie Roger
here they're clashing how shakuhaki was
powerful enough to crack the air and
generate a Shockwave that blew back
everything on the island as you would
expect he was also able to infuse his
weapon murakumogiri with his conquerors
hockey immensely increasing its strength
in his prime Whitebeard was basically
Unstoppable and could pretty much defeat
any character in the series I think we
can all agree that this Legend deserves
to be placed in god tier sengoku the
Buddha sengoku is actually the first and
only conquerors hockey user on this list
that isn't a pirate additionally he's
the only known Marine in the series
capable of using all three types of Aki
although Oda the creator of One Piece
confirmed that sengoku has conquerors
hockey we've never got to see him use it
as the former Fleet Admiral usually
stays out of combat however judging by
his reputation and Feats sengokusaki
should definitely be an a-tier Charlotte
leanley big mom big mom is one of the
most powerful characters in all of One
Piece and being a former Emperor she's
capable of utilizing all three types of
hockey she first showcased her Mastery
in using conquerors hockey at Sanju
pudding's wedding when she knocked the
man out for questioning her relationship
with Mother Carmel later when her
portrait of Carmel was destroyed a
distraught big mom Unleashed her hockey
again and incapacitated most of the
party guests she also has a rare ability
to infuse conqueror's hockey into
herself as signified by the Black
Lightning emanating from the infused
area this drastically increases her
attack power and combined with her
physical strength and Armament hockey
makes her pretty much Invincible the
best example is when she fought against
kaido at onigashima and The Clash of
their conquerors hockeys created a
massive Shockwave that split the heavens
as one of the former Emperors of the sea
big mom's hockey should be strong enough
to get her into a tier Charlotte
katakuri being undoubtedly the strongest
sweet Commander same as his mother
karakori managed to master all three
forms of hockey we've seen this when he
released a large burst of conquerors
hockey along with Luffy's own hockey in
order to knock out Charlotte flompe in
her subordinates as punishment for their
Interruption although katakuri is a very
strong pirate with a bounty of over 1
billion bellies Conker's hockey is not
his main weapon when it comes to combat
and he mostly relies on other hockey
types like observation therefore I'll
put him in B tier kozuki Odin although
Odin was a pirate for only five years he
achieved many great things like being a
part of both Whitebeard and Roger
Pirates and finding the laugh tale we've
seen Odin using conquerors hockey
multiple times throughout the series and
each time he managed to clash evenly
against very powerful opponents during
his initial encounter with Edward
Newgate 30 years ago the sudden clash
between them created a massive Shockwave
and an effect similar to lightning a
similar thing later happened in his
battle against kaido with whom Odin
clashed evenly despite kaido's inhuman
strain while not shown in the manga Odin
also used Conker's hockey's more common
effects in the anime once making a bunch
of kaido subordinates faint although
Odin showcased unprecedented Mastery of
conquerors hockey there were still some
characters he couldn't defeat and for
that reason I'll put him at the top of a
tier Captain Eustis kid according to
kaido kid possesses the ability to use
conqueror's hockey however so far in the
manga we didn't actually see him use
this ability due to the severe lack of
information and the fact that Shanks
overpowered him quickly with his own
hockey infused attack I'll have to put
kid in D tier for now Yamato the Oni
princess as the son of kaido it was only
natural for Yamato to develop incredible
Mastery over conquerors hockey he first
awakened it 20 years ago due to running
wild trout onigashima as a child and
knocking out kaido's subordinates as an
adult Yamato demonstrated its Advanced
application and was able to imbue his
weapon takeru with it this caused a
stream of Black Lightning to be emitted
from it as shown when performing rimei
hake and shin soku hakujaku even though
yamuno managed to fight against kaido
for some time it was obvious that her
Mastery over this power was nowhere near
his so I think B tier is a Fitting Place
for him kaido King of the beasts as the
former emperor of the sea kaido is one
of the most powerful pirates in the new
world he possesses immense Mastery in
using conquerors hockey as shown when he
clashed against a fellow Emperor big mom
producing a burst That Shook onigashima
and split the sky in two additionally
kaido can release extremely potent
bursts of hockey that can damage the
landscape around him and blow away
opponents same as a few of the previous
characters he can Infuse conqueror's
hockey into things particularly is
hasakai signified by the thin stream of
Black Lightning radiating from it when
using this ability along with his
natural physical strength kaido can
easily knock out even some of the most
powerful pirates in the series with only
a few strikes I wasn't sure if I should
put kaido in a or god tier but
considering that there's still some
characters with stronger hockey than his
I'll put him at the top of a tier Goldie
Roger the pirate king as the pirate king
and the man who conquered the ground
line Roger is the pirate with the
highest bounty in history what's even
more impressive is that he achieved all
this solely relying on his hockey
without ever eating a devil fruit his
usage of conquer his hockey was first
seen when he clashed with Whitebeard
causing a large hockey burst to travel
across the island and push back the Moby
Dick alongside the nearby trees clouds
and people he could also Infuse his
sword Ace with hockey and with only one
swing he could send a powerful combatant
like Odin flying miles away Roger is
truly one of the hockey Legends of the
one piece world and he definitely
deserves his spotting God
tiero the pirate Hunter for most of the
series The Power of conch hockey has
laid dormant within zardo without him
even knowing that he possesses it this
was first confirmed by kaido after the
emperor was struck by zoro's nine sword
style attack later during zoro's battle
against King he decided to go all out
and use his hockey at its maximum which
ended up knocking out multiple
low-ranked Beast Pirates causing him to
acknowledge he possessed it at the same
time he ended up using its Advanced
application infusing it into his three
swords with all three emitting streams
of Black Lightning as their battle
continued Zoro gained conscious control
over this power using it to deal
significant damage to King and
eventually defeat him although Zoro only
awakened this power recently he's
already shown great Mastery over it and
therefore I'll put him in B tier for now
however I definitely expect him to climb
through the rankings as the story goes
on fire Fist Ace as the son of the
pirate king Ace was bound to be a very
powerful pirate and had the
predisposition to develop an incredibly
strong hockey he did that at an early
age but initially had no conscious
control over it the first time we've
seen Asus this power was when he was
around 10 years old and rendered the
bluejam Pirates unconscious after an
outburst of Rage he later gained
knowledge of this power presumably when
he was a captain of the Spade Pirates or
when he joined Whitebeard unfortunately
since pre-time Skip One Piece didn't
really focus on hockey that much we've
never seen Ace use it therefore I can't
place him any higher than C tier
red-haired Shanks throughout the series
Shanks has often been portrayed as one
of the most powerful conqueror hockey
users in the entire world he was
actually the first person we see used
this mysterious power all the way back
in chapter one when he intimidated a sea
king with a single glare causing it to
flee for its life a bit later in the
story Shanks showcased his hockey
Mastery again when boarding whitebeard's
main ship there he was capable of
knocking dozens of whitebeards of men
unconscious many of whom were seasoned
Pirates able to survive the new world
while the flagship itself was damaged
from the sheer force of his presence
when Shanks and Whitebeard collided
their combined might even split the sky
in half although these events alone are
enough to solidify him as one of the
strongest hockey users ever Shanks
actually managed to impress us once
again during the wanowart here he
released a massive burst of conquerors
hockey that paralyzed Admiral greenbull
and prevented him from entering the
country What's even more impressive is
that Shanks was nowhere cool closed
captioning not available